Although today's date will forever be
associated with the jihadist massacre of
some 3,000 Americans, for centuries
earlier, September 11th was celebrated
as the day when a small band of
Christian knights defeated a massive
Muslim horde. Far from being a day of
defeat and mourning, it was a day of
victory and celebration. Here's a brief
summary. After continuously suffering at
the hands of the Knights of St. John,
also known as the hospitalers, a
Christian military order. The Islamic
Empire of the Ottoman Turks decided
enough was enough and declared a
full-blown jihad on Malta, the Knight's
headquarters. In the spring of 1565,
nearly 50,000 Muslims armed to the teeth
and with all sorts of heavy artillery
descended on the tiny Mediterranean
island, which was defended by the
Knights of St. John and a few thousand
shabily armed Maltese men. Enter Jean or
John Devallet, the master of the
knights. His disposition is rather sad,
wrote a contemporary. But for his age,
71, he is very robust and very devout.
As the vast Islamic Armada approached,
Master John gathered and told his
knights what was at stake. He said,
quote, "A formidable army composed of
audacious barbarians is descending on
this island. These persons, my brothers,
are the enemies of Jesus Christ. Today
it is a question of the defense of our
faith as to whether the gospel is to be
superseded by the Quran. God on this
occasion demands of us our lives already
vowed to his service. Happy will those
be who first consummate this sacrifice.
Meaning those who first become martyed
by Muslims. For the record, every
hospital or knight was, since her order
was first militarized over four
centuries earlier in the Holy Land,
vowed to fight to the death against, in
Master John's words, the enemies of
Jesus Christ, who were then known as
Sariss, Turks, andor Moors, in a word,
Muslims. Once the Turks arrived in May
of 1565, they subjected Malta, beginning
with the fort of St. Elmo, to what was
then the heaviest non-stop bombardment
of any local in history. With the roar
of the artillery, a chronicler wrote of
this siege, the hairraising screams, the
smoke and fire and flame, it seemed that
the whole world was at the point of
exploding. The vastly outnumbered and
soon weary knights who had been ordered
by Master John to quote, "Fight bravely
and sell your lives to the barbarians as
dearly as possible did just that." And
for every Christian killed defending the
forts of Malta, dozens of Muslim
besieggers died after storming the fort
of St. and Elmo and reducing it to
rubble. The Turks sadistically
slaughtered all its remaining defenders.
The Knights of St. John were literally
hung upside down from iron rings, had
their heads split, eyes gouged, their
chests open, and their hearts and
endrails pulled out and hurled to the
floor in full sight of the other forts.
The Muslim commander, Mustafa, then
ordered their mutilated corpses nailed
to wooden crosses and set a drift in the
grand harbor to mock and demoralize the
other Christian defenders. looking on
from their forts. The terror tactic
failed. The 71-year-old master John
Olette delivered a thundering and
defiant speech before the rest of the
knights and the terrified people of
Malta. Next, he beheaded all his Muslim
prisoners and fired their noggin from
cannon at the Turkish bescures. Not only
was this meant to avenge his fallen
brethren, it was meant to make the rest
of the Christians of Malta understand
that they were in a do or die situation,
for the Muslims would never show any
mercy after this act of defiance. The
Ottomans continued to subject the rest
of the tiny island, more a rock really,
to a sustained bombardment. Some 130,000
cannonballs were fired in total. I don't
know if the image of hell can describe
the appalling battle, wrote a
contemporary. The fire, the heat, the
continuous flames from the flamethrowers
and the fire hoops, the thick smoke, the
stench, the disembowled and mutilated
corpses, the clash of arms, the groans,
shouts, and cries, the roar of the guns,
men wounding, killing, scrabbling,
throwing one another back, falling and
firing. Although the rest of the forts
were reduced to rubble, much Muslim
blood was spilled for each inch gained.
For whenever they got within arms reach,
a historian writes, the scimitar was no
match for the long two-handed sword of
the Christians. Desperate fighting
spilled into the streets where even
Maltese women and children participated.
By late August, the island had still not
been taken. That and mass Muslim
casualties led to mass demoralization in
the Ottoman camp. Embarrassed talk of
lifting the siege had already begun when
a Sicilian relief force finally arrived
of some 10,000 soldiers at St. Paul's
Bay, the place where the famed apostle
was once shipwrecked. There, the final
scene of this Armageddon played out as
the fresh newcomers routed the
retreating Ottomans. The Muslims finally
fled and Malta was liberated on
September 11th, a day which for many
years thereafter was celebrated all
throughout Christrysendom until it was
supplanted with something else in the
year 2001.
I should let you know that the full
story of the 1565 siege of Malta is much
more dramatic, heroic, and inspiring
than this brief video, which barely
scratches the surface, can ever hope to
capture. Rather, this video is merely
meant to commemorate and summarize. If
you're interested in getting the full
story, which is much more epic and
amazing than any Hollywood movie, be
sure to get a copy of my forthcoming
book, The Two Swords of Christ, which
deals with both the Knights of the
Temple and the Knights of the Hospital,
the latter, also known as the Knights of
St. John. 35 pages of that book are
dedicated to this siege, recounting it
in full and gory detail. It truly
validates the saying that truth is
stranger than fiction.
Let us
[Music]